ok le chef kaki se veut reconnecter avec
similitants leur rappeler que c'est
l'économie et le nationalisme qui les
anime
mais on dirait que chaque fois qu'il
veut recadrer le message une nouvelle
diversion l'en empêche laissez-moi
terminer laissez-moi terminer encore
aujourd'hui son ministre de la Justice
tente de justifier la nomination d'un
ami personnel comme juge malgré la
perception d'un conflit d'intérêt j'ai
pris une décision que j'assume
relativement au fait que la personne a
été sélectionnée en fonction de ses
compétences souvent sur la défensive le
gouvernement logo ne parvient pas
facilement à suivre son programme
politique
est enthousiasmant on a des beaux défis
devant nous et on va les réaliser quoi
qu'on en dise certaines contreverses ne
veulent pas mourir comme l'abandon de la
promesse du troisième lien autoroutier
je parle au militaire on est à la même
place on a pleinement confiance à
Monsieur Lego par sa présence l'ancien
député de Beauce-Nord aujourd'hui
militants veut montrer que les délégués
de la Rive-Sud de Québec ne sont pas
tous frustrées
que vous pensez que ça va nuire à
Monsieur le bois en fin de semaine sur
cette décision là
dans la vie quand on est rendu d'or
qu'on en prend des décisions et en tant
que militaire je me dis c'est ça que ça
va arriver des affaires de même puis
mais on est là pour soutenir le parti le
à tout moment là pour soutenir leur chef
soumis à un vote de confiance demain
c'est possible qu'il y en ait une
minorité soit déçu de certaines
décisions mais moi j'essaye chaque jour
de prendre les meilleures décisions pour
l'intérêt commun donc pour l'intérêt de
l'ensemble des Québécois pour François
Le
Gault ramener à l'avant-scène l'identité
de la CAQ son entourage voit le Congrès
comme un point tournant un nouveau
départ après des décisions difficiles
ici Véronique prince Radio-Canada à
Sherbrooke